and I am with all my heart
that so little and is a very small measurement thank you
I am very happy
because I was just in a sulphur field
which was eliminated
but now he's alive again
My daughter was also here.
because we are in this option
And so I am very happy
and so we support and encourage
and we say something good in the opposite will of course
because different bushes is different
Like a lady on the shore yy
and Tarnowczyk is still some specific
Unfortunately
what we can do we convince
Anyway,
if people listened to yy and wanted to see
what are you doing
It would be necessary to convince me of holy words.
thank you very much
I would also like to
so that it was just
but I wish
Some friends of the lady are yy
here a friend
My friend is also a saint